♪ ♪ ♪
- Nous sommes sur la côte est
américaine, dans l'État
du Rhode Island.
En route, ou plutôt en mer
vers Block Island, qui
se trouve à environ une heure
du continent. Le vent souffle
fort : le vent, la principale
ressource naturelle de l'île.
Il doit souffler à au moins
10 km/h pour que les cinq
éoliennes y puisent leur énergie
pour approvisionner l'île
en électricité. Les éoliennes
en mer sont deux à trois fois
plus puissantes que
les éoliennes en terre.
Elles font partie du paysage
depuis 2016.
"Le nord-est du pays
est considéré comme l'Arabie
saoudite de l'énergie éolienne",
dit Bryan Wilson.
"Au total, les éoliennes
produisent 30 mégawatts
d'électricité", dit-il,
et il n'en consomme que 4 à 5
à son pic. Le reste est exporté
au continent. Ce sont des câbles
sous-marins ensevelis sous le
sable qui acheminent l'énergie,
orororord vers l'île,
puis vers le continent.
"C'est beaucoup mieux
maintenant", dit Judith Gray.
"Avant, l'électricité était
très instable. Elle fluctuait.
C'était terrible pour les
électroménagers. Il fallait
les remplacer constamment."
Avant, c'était quand
l'électricité provenait des
génératrices qui carburaient
au diesel. Les camions-citernes
arrivaient sur l'île en
traversier pour alimenter les
cinq génératrices qui brûlaient
à leur tour 4,5 millions
de litres de diesel chaque année
pour approvisionner l'île
en électricité.
"C'était bruyant, polluant
et peu fiable", nous dit
Jeffery Wright.
"Les éoliennes ont changé
la donne", dit-il.
"Elles ont changé notre vie."
"Ces génératrices ont s
jusqu'au 1er mai 2017, dit-il,
mais on les garde quand même
au cas où. Elles n'ont servi
que quatre à cin
depuis quatre ans."
s s s s s s moulins à vent en mr
ne font pas l'unanimité.
"J'espère qu'elêêêêêêtre
frappées par la foudre",
dit Rosemarie Ives, qui vit
quatre mois par année
à Block I
"Ce sont des intrus qui gâchen.
La maison appartient
à la famille depuis un siècle.
"C'est comme de la mauvaise
herbe, dit son mari, il faut
s'en débarrasser."
"Je préférerais mettr
panneaux solaires sur chaque
surface plate", dit-elle.
"Mais ce n'était pas une
option", nourererererereresse
de l'époque.
Mais les panneaux solaires font
u u u u u u u u paysage
à Block Island, comme ici,
à l'hôtel de ville.
Rosemarie Ives craintc c c c c ,
son bel horizon se transforme
en une gigantesque installation
industrielle.
Car Block Island sert un peu
de projet pilote pour le reste
des États-Unis.
"On va passer d'un projet
de 100 millions $ à un
de 100 milliards", dit-il.
"Il va y avoir des centaines,v,
à une trentaine de kilomètres
de la côte pour générer
de l'électricité à des millions
de personnes."
Wade Ortel voit tous ces
changements d'un bon oeil.
Un passionné de voitures, il
fait partie de cette génération
qui a grandi dans l'urgence
climatique.
Pour lui, la transition
énergétique est inévitable.
Sa coqueluche, c'est sa
coccinelle électrique,
qu'il a construite à l'âge
de 17 ans.
C'est en utilisan
vieux portables que l'adolescent
avait bâti son bolide.
"J'avais acheté plein
d'ordinateurs sur eBay, dit-il,
de vieux portables de bureau.
Je les avais démontés, et puis
j'ai testé chaque pile
pour en fair
de voiture.C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'e
voiture aux États-Unis, dit-il,
à être rechargée par
l'électricité qui provient
des éoliennes en mer."
L'impact du réchauffement
climatique se fait beaucoup L L,
comme beaucoup d'autres,
fait face à de l'érosion.
Chaque année, Rosemarie Ives
perd plus de deux mètres
de terrain et un peu plus loin,
la structure entière du phare
de l'île a dû être déplacée
de 91 mètres des falaises.
"La planète va survivre,
dit-il, mais peut-être pas nous.
Allons-nous l'endommageru'u'u'us
les bienvenus?"
"Je suis inquiet, mais j'ai
de l'espoir", dit Wade.
"C'est sûr que l'avenir
est sombre, mais il faut que
les gens se réveillente e e e er
les choses."
L'île tente de faire sa part
et plusieurs réfléchissent déjà
aux solutions alternatives
l l l l l l l l l l l l les câs
et les éoliennes seraient
sérieusement affectés
et que le prix du diesel
devienne inabordable.
"La prochaine étape est
le stockage d'énergie
dans les batteries", dit-il.
Wade Ortel n'a pas de téléphone
cellulaire, mais des projets
plein la tête, tel un jeune
Elon Musk, le fondateur de Tesla
et de SpaceX. Il circule
sur l'île sans faire de bruit.
Mais il y a aucun doute
pour lui : l'avenir est
dans l'énergie renouvelable.olos
continuent de tourner pour
révolutionner tranquillement
toute la côte est américaine.
♪ ♪